all right so let's um get into this um a
little bit about my background I am a
biologist by trade nothing to do with
plant um I worked at the DNA level at
Indiana University um I recently retired
last year um but everything I've I've
learned in terms of fruit growing and
stuff has been in the last eight years
typically through people who are doing
the growing themselves so why fix um
this is not something that is common
here in the Midwest however there is a
demand for fresh DS in the midwest um
especially down um where I'm from I I
lived in Bloomington Indiana Indiana
University and I was also a student at
Purdue um a wide diversity of folks in
those areas many of them coming from
California or warmer regions or
countries where figs are common and
people eat them every day if you want to
get a fresh fig here in the Midwest kind
of good
right not easy and if you do get them
here they've been shipped from
California or someplace else and by the
time they get here they've been on a
truck for months or weeks or whatever
and they're not going to be great so we
know that there's a demand for fresh
digs if you can get them to grow um you
can probably command a very good amount
of money for what you grow so it is a
niche market um and so our goal in this
project is to work out the conditions
where more farmers can start growing
fresh pigs on a small scale scale or
bigger scale and provide them to local
markets if there will be an interest
okay um the beauty of things unlike
other fruits and and I'm not going to
get into you know the growth of a big
and whether not it's really a fruit or
not but um if you're growing apple pear
Peach um Simon pawpaw whether it's
native or non-native you're going to
take years before that tree can give you
fruit all right so the beauty of fig is
you can actually start to get bigs on
Oney old's
trees um and if if the stars align and
the climate is great and everything is
is perfect you can actually get a second
prop which is called a breva um the the
main crop is in the summer fall mostly
towards fall um but the secondary crop
can be in the spring right the main crop
grows on um New Growth from the season
the secondary bre cop crop uh grows on
last year's growth I won't talk about
the breba crop very much but um I can
direct you to some reading if you're
interested in
thats WR way all right so about this
project it's a partnership um and the
goal in this part this this partnership
it it includes three farms and we're
looking at um the production of cold
hearty fig varieties there's cold cold
hearty and not cold hearty so there's
two kinds we're looking at zones five
and six which covers Indiana and other
areas in the north central region and
our goal is to kind of try and establish
the best conditions for growing those
figs and providing new opportunities to
you guys as Farmers so those are the
main
goals and let's talk about what cold
hearty figs really mean
so a cold hearty fig typically and if
you if you've heard of fig Chicago Hardy
is probably the one you've heard of the
most it grows beautifully you can get
fixed if everything the stars align and
you don't get an early Frost but then if
you get uh temperatures below 20 degrees
that thing is going to dive back to the
ground and then it just Springs back on
it's like a peral comes back year after
year
ideally we would like to not let it die
back to the ground we'd like to get
conditions where the above ground part
stays alive and gives you a jump start
on the next on the year's growth the
following year so that you get F more
figs and you get figs um before the
frost so that's the goal so when we talk
about cold hearty figs we're talking
about figs that
survive and act kind of like as a
perennial they'll dive back to the
ground they'll come back but we're also
going to look at trying to not get them
to dive back to the ground that makes
sense for
everybody all right so the three Farms
involved in this project um I'll just
call them Farm one Farm two Farm three
like thing one thing two thing three and
drus um Farm one is my place down in
Green County I'm in Salsbury you've
heard of the Tulip Trestle that's I'm
just like three miles down the road from
the Tulip Trestle in the railroad L of
my property um we are Zone 6B now we
were 6A we've transitioned to 6B because
it's getting warmer um Farm 2 um Mimi
and Evan uh you heard them speak this
morning about the truffles they're in uh
par
County um which is right up here um and
they are now Zone 6A you wore 5B correct
yeah and then Zone 5B all the way up in
St Joseph at the very top um we're
looking at Big growth up there as
well all
right so the project overview when we
wrote this grant uh we said we would do
it on multiple Farms that's part of the
partnership in the USDA a program um we
said we would focus on three three cold
hearty varieties the ones that we
finally chose were Chicago hardy which
is kind of the the one that everyone has
heard of the most and is probably grown
the most um the uh other one Syrian dark
and the third one Abu George um those
are all cold hearty varieties and I will
get into why we chose them in a little
bit um um and then we're testing those
both in ground and comparing that to Big
thrown in pots so those three varieties
growing them in ground and those three
varieties grown in pots so the ones in
the ground were winterizing them so that
they try to survive and don't die back
to the ground and then the one the same
ones in pots we're putting them into um
a protected uh out building or garage
and over win again that way a lot of
people do this they grow fix and pots in
this area especially hobbyists and pull
them into their garage they do need to
go dormant
um but we're looking at the we're
comparing the two to see if we can get
those field ones to grow and you don't
have to worry about dragging pots in and
out every year the third component that
we said we would look at and I'm not
going to talk much about this today
because we haven't done a whole lot on
this yet is looking at Living mulches
that might complement the figs so um can
we possibly get a second crop out of
that same space um or can we put
something in there that's going to
protect the soil or provide more
nutrients to the soil so depending on
your interest there's you know different
ways to approach this but we do want to
keep the soil protected um and know
maybe get another crop out of it
something that um might be worthwhile at
Market so the three again that we're
focusing on are Chicago hardy Syrian
dark Abu George um each Farm is growing
minimally four if not five of each of
those in ground and also in
pots um these were recommended To Us by
Darren at brambleberry Farm if you're
familiar with Darren um and Darren had a
number of other cold hearty ones that he
started to play around with and he
thought might be fun for us so he uh we
got several of those from him um and
we're just kind of testing them here and
there they're not um on all three Farms
across the board un Ely but um we are
getting a little bit of data out of
these as we've uh started growing them
Brooklyn dark Brooklyn white brown
turkey that's probably the other one
that people have heard of the most
Gino's black um Lula LSU gold it was
created I believe at LSU University or
Lis
University magbar Hardy which Darren
believes is probably Chicago hardy but
there's a story behind it um Magnolia
Rond de Bordeaux sunflower and Viet de
bordo so let's start with the inground
fig what did we do so we uh Darren
rooted sign messenger if you're not
familiar with what that is is when the
figs go dormant you collect um Twigs off
of them usually oneye old growth and
then for figs you can actually root
those in sand or a combination of sand
and perite or sand and Peete Moss they
root very easily and then you start a
whole new tree that way so Darren did
this for us last
winter and we obtained those from him in
April of this past
year we got them planted the first
weekend in June which is a little late
but because the project wasn't awarded
until um later in the spring we had to
go with what we could do um so we
planted them the first weekend in June
and we planted them with a lot of
compost each Farm got a little a little
bit different amounts of compost and
that was based solely on how we dug the
holes so my farm farm one we don't have
a tractor we don't have mechanical stuff
we dug our holes by hand um so we did
not dig them very deep um and we didn't
put a lot of compost in Mimi and Mimi's
farm farm two and the farm farm three
they mechanically dug their holes so
their holes were deeper um and so a lot
more compost went into those holes just
kind of by
default mulching we uh or covering the
soil the bare soil that was there we did
that various ways my farm on Farm one we
put down a ton of cardboard and wood
chips so that we weren't um getting a
lot of weeds and that we were keeping
the soil um from being Fried by the this
the hot sun uh Mimi you guys did wood
chips and straw or straw wood chips for
for um
the mulching straw was for for the
winter yeah and then Farm three they use
landscape fabric up there watering
typically weekly but you know we had a
drought last year and so in some cases
we were watering a little more
frequently the original goal in the
project was to grow all of these trees
upright um so that we could then cage
them and protect them in the winter um
however between the time the Grant was
um awarded or actually around the time
it was awarded Mimi went to Japan and
was able to see some um installations
where they're growing figs in an
espalier or Cordon style which means
you're training them and in this case
they're being trained to load to the
ground in a horizontal way so that you
can protect them a little bit more and
they they can benefit from um the soil
or the Earth as a thermal mass in the
winter time
um like a step
overhead no so we'll get into what this
looks like in a second yeah so Farms one
and two my farm and n's Farm um are
using this different support system than
what we originally said we would do farm
three is sticking with the original
upright um support system that we'll go
into so this is what the Cordon system
looks like so um basically we have taken
and um hammered down down in a pipe it
could be either aluminum or steel um
down two feet into the ground leaving
one foot above the ground and then um
running a horizontal aluminum pipe down
the
row and then planting
um two
figs water bottle in my phone these are
two figs planting them with in a foot of
each other letting them grow up and then
letting them train this way along the
pole
so you're getting bigs coming up
training them to go horizontally away
from each
other and Loosely tying them down not
touching the aluminum pipe but just
tying them down so they start to train
once they're
trained um you don't need that pipe
really technically anymore but it'll
probably stay there for long it um and
then you plant two that way and then
eight later you plant another two So
eventually two coming up are going to
meet each other at some point point but
we'll keep them pruned and trained so
that they're not um interfering with
each other we're also if you'll notice
so you see cattle panel off to the right
um we put cattle panel both on either
side of the figs eventually to protect
them from Deer this also serves to help
us when we do the winterization this was
probably the most expensive part of the
project but it's a one andone once you
do it you don't have to do it again the
panels come down very easily so if you
want to get in and weed or pick figs um
they're 8ot cattle panel and you just
tie them down you know tie them to the
to the uh the chost you could just
easily take those down and get in there
and work with the
pigs any questions about
this so just give a little plug here so
this is an example on the right of what
a cordon fig looks like so this is one
that Dr Lee Reich has um uh posted in
his book growing figs in cold climates
um it's a very easy read if you're
interested uh but he has grown one of
his figs low to the ground um you can't
see it in this picture he did not use an
aluminum pipe to train it along he
actually just bent it over and secured
it down to the ground there's cheap and
easy ways you can do this um and this
one's probably been there for quite a
while but then you can see new Season's
growth shooting upwards about every
couple
inches and the idea is that fix start to
grow on that new growth every
year and so you get multiple places and
it's easy to go in and just quickly pick
those sticks as they
grow all D or what
what's they're in in Big World I'm wrong
I don't think there's any dwarf or semi
dwarf pigs so do all the same yeah yeah
and you just you're prone and train as
you need it won't if you just let them
go they're going to get maybe 15t tall
oh really and they'll look like a big
bush Okay um we'll do the same thing on
the on
the go 15 they could training for
time you know so if they are in a high
tunnel you suspend those new growths the
stems from the
ceiling yes
yes um in terms of D Scott the third F
uh he do
so and that's true for any fruit tree
you can you can train a regularly sized
fruit tree to be dwarf it's a lot of
pruning so if you stay on top of the
pruning you can you can manage a tree
and keep it keep it small okay I've seen
you know I've seen people growing apple
trees in a pot for 20 years and they
stay small so yeah and you you sourced
your um actual starts I guess brand be
from brambleberry brambleberry yeah
brambleberry Farm in P Indiana um if you
Google them you'll find them Darren is
free own that they will not ship you
have to go visit and it's worth the
visits not been to their place um it's a
lovely place to visit because they grow
all sorts of cool things down
there those all came from
anars and I I'm happy to share that
information I'll give youil
all right let's turn to the Potted F fix
so again we want to compare inground
versus
potted um so we did pretty much the same
thing what the same size plants oneyear
old or slightly less that had been
rooted by by Darren at brambleberry we
he got we got them in small pots about a
four to a liter in size um we kind of
kept them in those small pots to get
them well established um probably kept
them a little too long but we hit that
drought in the summer and so it just
it was kind of a half dozen or the other
we ended up up potting them to 10 gallon
pots in early
August
um we I did not mulch I don't think you
mulched them did you put any wood chips
or anything on top not initially not
initially yeah um but we will definitely
be doing that this year you could do
wood chips you could do leaf mulch um
anything to kind of keep a lot of
evaporation from happening um that way
you can keep your watering down a little
bit and then we watered weekly or is
needed just like with the inrs no
support system at the moment um if we
want them to grow really tall we could
add um some sort of U like a bamboo post
or something in there to kind of help
stabilize those but again you can you
can prune and manage them and keep them
small and it depends on your
goal do they require a lot of water as
well you
know um I was watering mine so mine was
on the west side of an out building so
it wasn't on the south side it was on
the west side and so it did get some
morning shade I think I was watering
maybe a gallon once or twice a week each
of
those mine was on the west mine was on
the west side of an building so it was
not getting Morning Sun um they were
finally getting Sun about um 11:00 or
noon they did do really
well yours is in full correct yeah yeah
yeah and I looking at yours versus m
suffer a little more
and that is one thing with with the Paw
I mean they're great in theory because
they're mobile and you can move them
around but if you go on vacation or if
you ignore them or you forget about them
you know they could suffer and so that's
one of the reasons why I think it's
really important that they get covered
with something like wood mulch I can
also tell you I have outdoor working
cats um and they love it as a litter box
so
um so yeah so this year I will
definitely be covering mine so that The
Cats won't get into it and it won't be
this moisture loss and those pots are
just plastic pots or they're yeah
they're heavy industrial molded plastic
pots get them from Amazon I think they
were remember what we paid I would say
for 20 pots it was like $10 a
pot and dra yes yeah
but they're not they're just about the
right size so if
you I let mine almost dry out or get you
know low moisture so I can pick them up
and move them but you know that's a lot
on your back so you could easily take a
dolly and Slide the dolly in and roll
them from place to place as long as
you've got something to roll that Dolly
on so that's do
that there's
a a plant shot Nursery not far from
where we live they also do landscaping
and in the back of it they have what
they call a graveyard and that's where
they put all the pots that they from
their landscaping and anybody can go in
and again with no charge oh nice so that
might be
something all right so let's talk about
buling um
so one of the goals in the project that
we said we would do was try to explore
some living mulches um or perhaps a
secondary crop that help keep that bare
soil from uh drying out and and and
losing
nutrients um we have not really explored
that too much and if you thought what I
said earlier all of us kind of did
something a little bit different so um
my farm the inground uh figs got
cardboard couple layers of cardboard
followed by um mulch that I just got at
the local Nursery so it's a it was aged
um
uh wood mulch uh Mimi used mulch
originally um we'll talk about what we
did for winter mulching and protection
that's a little bit different with chip
mul we also planted the made of
strawberry oh on one end okay just to
see what happened and it it's there it
grows and it it's it pretty much
withstands like foot traffic um so I I
it was just a test right so as a as a
has a ground cover ground cover just to
deter
weed and I may consider on my property
putting in mint or another herb that's
more aromatic that will heat graab away
um and I do a lot
of later but um so another possibility
is an herb that might help protect um
and also keep some away
winterization let's talk about
winterization so um we have to protect
them in Winter and again one of our
goals to see if we can keep those sticks
from dying back to the
ground Darren all of his figs down at P
he never does any winterization and he
says all of them die back to the ground
so that's kind of our starting point
there um I do know people who have
winterized their cold their Chicago
Hardies and had some success at keeping
them from dying back um what we're doing
on Farm one and two again we're using
that Porton system so we're growing
those figs low to the ground that's
taking advantage of the thermal mass of
the Earth which means they're going to
stay a little bit warmer for a little
bit longer down close to the ground and
then we're covering them with a ton of
straw you'll see a picture of this in
the moment
um for 16 figs that I had in a row it
took 10 to 12 bales of straw to give you
an idea to cover those Farm three
they took a different approach they used
burlap um I'm wrong here in saying wire
cages they didn't use wire cages I'll St
about what they used and they used some
leaf mulch to protect we'll show you
pictures of what they did and then the
pots they got moved into an indoor space
you can let these figs stay out they can
they can handle a frost they can handle
multiple Frosty frosts they just can't
handle extended periods below 20° so all
of us left our P our potted figs outside
until late November early December and
that's when you do the you really want
them out there because you want them to
go dormant the figs need to go through a
dormy period so you want them to kind of
be um exposed to those cold temperatures
so they lose their leaves and they go
into that dormant phase and then you
pull them inside or protect
them so inground this is what the ingr
ones look like on Farm one and two um
you can see we've got mult couple rows
here and the cat cattle panels are down
for the moment so they could get in
there and cover those figs with straw um
and again you want to just cover them as
much as possible um I learned um that
straw settles with time especially when
you get snow so you want to put way more
straw than you think you need it's going
to settle through time
um it didn't take as long as I thought
it would and I also had um my nieces and
nephews help me and the fun family
project uh um so it didn't really take
long to do it we just got them covered
um and then they just stay there all
winter long Shing a little nap Farm
three um they approach theirs a little
bit differently so they've got the
landscape fabric they did if you see the
top left photo they first kind of
wrapped the fs first a little bit um
with some burlap and then they um used
tar paper which is the roofing stuff
it's it's um used for roofs and it's in
permeable terrain they used they used a
couple toost and they just kind of
wrapped it around the toost put tons of
leaves down in there and then wrapped
again with burlap you'll see that um
Carry there on at the bottom left she's
wrapping with burlap over the taret
paper and then the final step is put a
bucket on top but you're not getting ton
of ring there are those pred down before
they wrapped them um did you say pruned
pruned yes cut down yes I don't think so
um we'll talk about how much growth they
had eventually in if they in future
years they might have to yeah because
this is first year this first
year yeah they they will get into this
but um here their Farm I think um I'll
show you the tallest one how tall it got
but it didn't get above those two posts
so all right so what did we observe
these first five months I really did not
expect I mean we were just hoping that
everything would survive simple you're
one get everything to to survive but we
did I did do some observations on growth
um we did kind of check here and there
for disease and pest pressure and then
of course we didn't really expect to get
figs but we were kind of surprised so
we'll talk about
that all right so growth in year one so
those figs started out about this tall
okay um um this is Mimi uh she's on Farm
2 Zone 6A this was the tallest fig uh in
in the group um this was the LSU gold
fig um and so there was a ton of growth
on that particular tree most of the
trees depending on where they were in
the plots grew anywhere from 2 feet to
four feet um in one year's
time uh the picture on the right is Farm
three and I believe that was the tallest
F that they had um on on their plot of
16 quite one year right because this is
in like early late summer yes yeah so
this is went in brown on June first week
yep and yeah so they grow fast that's a
plus um and so uh this this year I'll go
through and do a very um careful
analysis of how much grow on each
variety so I I was seeing some uh some
differences um and I'll kind of mention
those here in a second um I in zone in
zone 6B Farm one I had the least amount
of growth as everybody which is kind of
in a way surprising but maybe not
because a I didn't use as much compost
as the other two farms and B mine was in
a really lazing hot field and so I'm
thinking that I may consider in the
future using maybe a 30% shade cloth
during the really hot months just to to
give them a little bit of a break we'll
see was that in the system where you
were trying
to before it it was before we before you
yeah this is kind of late summer and it
wasn't until fall like before the winter
that really started training to yes so
get them a good growth before this is
the tree not shoot off right so IDE
start well this is like you know the
first few months so I started training
after start training in the
fall
yeah yeah somewhere in there and then we
started I think we started training TI
it was cold when I started tying them
down start cold so they're really
flexible yeah yeah they're pretty
flexible so you know I I think you tie
them down to where you think you know it
feels pretty good and I use cotton by
the way all cotton just
spray and then and then like you come
back a week later or two you can tie it
down even tighter because you know you
trained Stu
give just the compost
and what do they
require they're pretty I think they're
pretty forgiving um we have not done
soil test that's something I should have
done last year we I'll do this um and I
I'll actually give you a little bit of
insight so um on me so Mimi has the most
figs um there's kind of a story behind
that I won't go into but um Farm one and
farm three we have 16 figs in ground
Mimi that iot 4 or something like
that yeah okay yeah she's got a lot so
she's got the both of the Oddball ones
that we have um but on the space that we
planted those in I noticed pretty
quickly and I'll show this to you in a
easier thing um figs at one part of the
property are growing really well at the
other end they the growth was really
short sted and we do know if there was a
house or a building on that place yeah
so yeah this was the hill to hill now
yeah um and it had old house that yeah
I've never seen the house it was already
destroyed all it had was like concrete P
left or whatever so we were going to do
the WAP that's what happened right and
the price like okay so all this is
planted on top of that hill without
any uh admendment to the soil other than
the compost where we the that was just
and so to see this grow
right I'm thinking that the area that
you had the least amount of growth was
probably where the main part of the
house might have been sit the both ends
so it's really hard for me to say that
okay you would think the house was more
Central for some reason that's yeah I
don't know and I say that because I have
black wall not planting we pl we had an
old house sitting down and we can we
knew where the house was CU we were the
ones who took it down we put black
walnuts and you can tell exactly where
that house was because those trees are
5T and the ones in the perimeter where
the house wasn't they're now
20t so you can tell there's a huge
difference in what the soil was I mean I
sat there for over 100 years so um
interesting so oh now that you mention
one so we cleared that entire Hillside
or the hill thinking we're gon to put in
a wall of paint right so they basically
raised all of the trees and leaves
whatever was in there and there was a
huge
Walnut W on the North side and actually
Matthew lot of
wals yeah it's possible there yeah so
they may resist
don't know we still have
around yeah we got
that so disease and pest pressure so um
I mean pretty this is first year so it's
really hard to say um I think the
biggest thing that we battled was the
drought you know keeping things from
frying and that just required a little
extra water here there um I never saw
any um I mean we got them in late so I
think we kind of missed the Japanese
beetle phase um did that how that
coincide for you yeah no it overlapped
because we got them in yeah it was
directly at the same time as the Japan
be Japanese beetles in our field
this the pigs they they didn't seem to
like them or something thank goodness
they didn't go up to Fig Hill so I mean
they're kind of close by but I don't
know we'll just have to
see that's interesting so then the next
question is Big production so in theory
oh go
ahead I so I'm assuming that the bigs
currently are still covered up yes so
you really couldn't report on
like B
I'll talk about
that very good question um so before we
get to that let's talk about fig
production So in theory first year figs
should give
um should give fix however considering
that we didn't get these until the first
weekend in June I point I don't think
either one of us really expected to get
F right fix at
all we did we got things so um all three
of the main ones Chicago hardy Syrian
dark Abu
George I observed figs on all of those
at Mimi's place um on my place I had a
couple figs on Syrian dark um and I
think Farm 3 got a couple figs as well I
don't know which one they got it was
like me they didn't get that many so we
didn't really document that too well
Mimi's place she also had figs on
Brooklyn dark Brooklyn white brown
turkey Gino's black Lillo LSU gold and
the Magmar Hardy
the uh Magnolia is not in her place it's
in my place in a pot no figs um Ronda
Bordeaux sunflower and vet they were all
at one end and that's one of the areas I
think it's the soil um so they didn't
grow nearly as much and they also didn't
produce very many figs so there could be
something with the soil there that we
need to um check on a little bit closer
um the Potted figs I don't think any of
the Potted figs or potted fig trees
produce figs
so that's something worth noting as well
and were they planted pots did you just
use um compost or what kind of soil we
used to be kind of across the board
something that we all had access to we
just went to Menards and we bought um
The Miracle Grow organic and another one
just potting soils ra bed bed soils okay
so a question for you on the
there's a there's a variety I really
want to grow but it's I've avoided it
because it's Zone 8 n do you know the
zones on these and are any of them like
specifically a higher Zone that you
actually got fruit on um so all of these
are considered quote unquote cold hardy
so that they they've been tested they
you know hobby Growers have been growing
them in these scolder climat okay they
might not be
zon 89 used to I just want that tiger
pach one yeah that's really cool looking
but I it just seemed like a waste of
money if I knew it was gonna die if you
have the ability to bring it into a
garage it's well worth it okay um
there's a guy here in
Indianapolis um who grows 50 different
varieties on his little Urban plot and
he pulls them into a garage every winter
and he get Fs on all of them so all
po yes
y yeah you different varieties so you
could definitely do that if you want to
bring it inside I mean one's okay I'm
not sure
right
yeah on it but I I I'm not as familiar
with these warmer growth ones but they
probably need to go through a slight D
SC check
that all right so here's the Fig I look
like okay
um one of things that I know Mimi did
when she started to see the figs and it
was getting really late in the fall you
know to kind of enhance rening she
actually plucked a lot of the leaves off
so they get more
sun um Lee Reich in his book talks about
you can enhance potentially Quicken the
ripening by putting a little drop of oil
on the eye so you can see you know like
olive oil or something right there at
that little point that little eye that
supposedly is supposed to help enhance
the ripening
um but yeah she got fresh shs so that's
pretty
cool so let's talk um a little bit about
thinking outside the box so if you ever
write a USC Grant or any Grant
whatsoever I've been writing grants for
a long time in my capacity at NIU you
always want to think what if what if
this doesn't work what can be salvaged
from this because people who are
reviewing grants and they're going to
give you money they want to know that
it's worth something in some form
fashion whether it's education or can
you get something else out of this and
so when we wrote this grant we really
kind of thought about outside the box
what happens if we do all of this and we
just can't get a lot of right things you
know we don't want Farmers to go through
all of this and all of a sudden say gosh
you know I invested all this money I did
all this work and now I have nothing to
take to Market so thinking outside the
box um we in the grant that we would
look at some other value added things
that could come out of these figs even
if you didn't get right
figs or didn't get very many rights so
it turns out that you can make some
value outed products from um fig trees
whether you get ripe or unripe figs or
none at all so you can definitely make
Jam jams from Ripe figs if you are
familiar with uh Dylan Farm they make
something called the Frog Jam which is
is fig
Orange uhr Raspberry G I think it's
grape so they blend three different
fruits and make this fantastic Jam if
you've not tasted it I highly recommend
uh going to your grocery store and
looking for
dilman you can also it turns out make
jams from unrip figs and so this is one
of those uh made me collected a bunch of
unrip figs froze them down um I just got
them from her yesterday or today
and I'm going to go play around with
some recipes I I know of one farm that
has made um jam from unrip figs so I'm
going to play around with that and see
what that comes out to be okay but
that's definitely a possibility you can
make teas turns out figs whether it's
the figs or the leaves are highly highly
nutritional there's a lot of vitamins in
them a lot of
antioxidants um I can direct you to
research uh published papers on that if
you're interested um you can have you
can make a fig leaf tea of just the Fig
leaves Alone um I know me you love just
plain fig leaf tea um I collected fig
leaves off of these figs and I blended
them with some herbal uh dried herbal uh
things that are often used in peas
you're going to get to taste that today
um so there's definitely a market there
um I talked to um a woman who owns a um
she owns an Apothecary but she also has
a wild food uh bar in Greenwood it's
it's open to the public and they make um
they make drinks and they make uh soups
and things out of either wild Foods or
herbales and I
said if we had farmers who could Supply
you with fig leaves would you be
interested her eyes went oh
yes so there are herbalists out there
who would gravitate to this in a
heartbeat if you produce
this um we talked about living mulches
that are a secondary crop so let's say
you don't want to collect uh you don't
want to make
jam um but you got another living mulch
under there so you could eventually get
um two things out of it you get the tea
the leaves from the Fig for teas you
could um have a secondary crack of
something underneath whether it's
strawberries or something um else that
somebody might be interested in there's
also a fourth thing that I I I'll just
mention
um I don't know anyone doing it but um
sober Mak a farm in Bloomington um if
you're familiar with thatan Carlos is
from South America and in South America
they use uh the sap which is a latex
like um sap they use that medically for
um skin growths warts and things like
that just put a little dat of that sap
on it and the W disappears so it's
actually very traditional down there I'm
sure not well researched here uh but
something that that could potentially
down the line to get if you are allergic
to latex then you may not want to be
delving into that and if you are
allergic to latex the tees are probably
fine but you know don't risk it if you
are allergic to latex um but you will
get to taste some te here in a
second all right so I talked about this
early on um part of this grant also was
an educational component in speaking
here today is part of that um our we
promised in our grant that we would
reach a wide range of of farmers here
and that's why I sent that little uh
clipboard around if you are a female
farmer um a military veteran farming or
interested in farming or bipac or you
fall into more than one group um if you
would just let me know so that um I can
give that feedback to s that would be
wonderful um we will be giving more
updates through the North American fruit
explorers and the Indiana fruit nut
growers association again we've got
stuff up here that you can take from
those groups those were probably be via
zoom and I think um we'll try to have a
field day some at some point next year
this is a two-year Grant so we need to
do something in the field before the
grant is over and then lastly we'll do
some feedback you'll give you some
feedback on the sampling of the tea
today and with that um we want to thank
USDA and sah for funding this project I
think it's going to be really cool with
um offering some new opportunities to
far Farmers here in the Midwest the
North American fruit explorers um
they're the so when you do a partnership
they typically want an entity that um
kind of supports you so that all the the
money routes through them so the North
American food explorers graciously
offered to do that for us they get
nothing out of this they just are the
conduit through which everything goes
and then the Indiana fruit and nut
Growers assoc nut Fruit Growers
Association um again they they help
support um all of our local fruit nut
growing farmers and so um I I want to
thank them too because they are allowing
us to publish some stuff in in their
journals and give talks and things like
that so if you want to reach me my phone
number is up there um I don't usually
answer my phone you have to leave a
message um you can also email me or you
can reach me either through NX or the
Indiana net Fruit Growers I'm the
president of both and I'm the one that
sees most of those emails so
[Music]